In the US, House Judiciary Committee Chairman Jerrold Nadler issued a subpoena...
...to get special counsel Robert Mueller's full report...
...on his investigation into Russia's meddling in the 2016 US national election.
In Sudan, thousands of demonstrators performed Friday prayers...
...outside of the army headquarters in the capital, Khartoum.
In Northern Ireland, journalist and author Lyra McKee was shot and killed...
...following overnight rioting in the city of Londonderry.
In Mali, Prime Minister Soumeylou Boubeye Maiga and his entire government...
...resigned amid an uptick in violence in the country.
Finally from the Philippines, devout Catholics in the province of Pampanga...
...marked Good Friday with a reenactment of the crucifixion of Jesus Christ.